render their love in the shadow of
washington's monuments on the eve of his
inauguration
joe biden did something his predecessor
never has a national moment of mourning
for the now four hundred thousand
victims of covid19
a crisis certain to dominate the start
of his presidency
to heal we must remember
it's hard sometimes to remember
but that's how we heal it's important
to do that as a nation that's why we're
here today
between sundown and dusk let us shine
the lights
in the darkness along the sacred pool of
reflection
remember all whom we lost the symbolism
of a new look in washington was powerful
at the place he will soon call home the
outgoing president had delivered the
case for the defense
of his presidency i took on the tough
battles
the hardest fights the most difficult
choices
because that's what you elected me to do
i want you to know that the movement we
started
is only just beginning there's never
been anything
like it and 78 days after the election
these wishes for his successor this week
we
inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck
in such unprecedented times it will be
an inauguration unlike any before it
on the national mall a field of flags
each one representing a person
who can't be there already altered by a
pandemic
shut down as a public event after the
storming of the capital
a sign of the edginess a dozen members
of the national guard have been removed
from duty
some for their ties to far-right groups
the inauguration is traditionally the
biggest party that washington throws but
everything is so different this year
empty streets fences
the national guard that it's telling of
a real nervousness in america
and indicative of the country that joe
biden is about to inherit
the us capital laid on quite a show at
sunset a city
and a country scarred by the last two
weeks and divided by the last four years
and uncertain of what its new dawn will
bring
greg milam sky news washington